wait no I thought I was here to talk
about my problems yes heterosexuality is
a problem
today you're here for straight
conversion therapy we're of the opinion
that heterosexuality is a mental illness
and an addiction that we need to work
through I know that like in middle
school I like you know had some like
boy-crazy moments but like I didn't
think it was that bad like let's talk
about your childhood what we've
typically found is that there's some
sort of childhood trauma that has made
you straight no yeah so I've always been
straight watching my parents have a
loving relationship 45 years old I got a
little bit of a reputation on the
schoolyard for being a heartbreaker like
I was always just attracted to females
that's just mm that doesn't make any
sense to me and I know there must have
been some trauma that you can't remember
then that we're going to have to bring
out here in these therapy sessions I
like to tell moms
if you don't hug your sons some other
woman will I I mean I don't I don't I
don't think that's the case so what I'd
like to do is I'd like to examine these
heterosexual urges you feel I pulled up
a picture of a woman here and I want you
to take a look at it I have here a
picture of a man
well it's Mila Kunis she's stunning
she's wearing it especially um busty
dress oh my gosh I feel like I look at
his picture and I instantly blush and
he's a little like nice tan secret under
my look what ah the goal of the version
therapy is to introduce a negative
stimulus in the future when you see a
man you might associate this negative
stimulus with that you spitting water on
me okay so when I think about hot guys
I'm just gonna get wet that's why you're
just itching that seems like it's doing
more like permanent mental harm I don't
think you spraying me with water is
going to prevent me from wanting to make
out with Zac Efron do we need to try
like shocking you oh I think that's kind
of bullsh
okay so finally I want to try some
behavioral change therapy if we
encourage homosexual behavior then the
feelings might follow I mean
okay do you have a cat oh yeah lots of
cat okay you're basically halfway there
already you should go home and maybe
watch Brokeback Mountain a couple times
okay what your man friend over and just
see what happens I'm not trying to like
hook up with a dude how many flannel
shirts maybe like four for the winter
that's pretty good I would recommend
maybe getting one or two more just so
you have like one for every day of the
week you know okay it sounds like it's
really expensive to be gay maybe try
taking up wrestling is a sport see how
that works
what's gay about wrestling I am a
likeable person so I have one more
question for you
are you gay now did it work no
everything you have said to me today has
had zero effect on my sexuality I like
who I like it's pretty that's pretty
much all there is to it
reparative therapy views most same-sex
attractions as reparations for childhood
trauma I would be pretty offended if
someone were to say you're just straight
because you probably got molested when
you were a kid I think it's a little
tough to just assume that everyone who's
gay had I got romantic childhood
beginning in the 1930s aversion
techniques were used to eliminate or
diminish an undesired response by
repeatedly pairing the undesired
response with an unpleasant condition so
basically they are zapping people
whenever they look at naked people of
the same gender I think it would make
you afraid to have feelings about
anything I don't think it would like
make you straight I don't think it
really works I don't think people should
be doing it it's probably just more
harmful I don't see how it could work
it's here it's here
Karen what get it
they're hotter gotta get it get it and
get it it's here quick